no that's not photoshop
that's an actual video from the
international space station of the moon
looking
a bit squished
wow so
what happened here
is the cover-up behind a flat moon an
elaborate government conspiracy
how would this affect the oceans
what would happen to our climate
and could the moon fly out into space
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the moon was flat
in 2010 an astronaut on the
international space station observed a
bizarre phenomenon
when he glanced out the window he saw
the moon looked flattened when it
appeared in the thickest part of the
earth's atmosphere
and those of you in the flat earth
society
don't add me
it's not flat
high above the planet the air bends
light to give the moon this squished
look in these very specific conditions
but if the moon were flat
it would explain why we never see the
mysterious dark side
and
if this was our reality
how would this affect gravity on earth
okay there are no illusions this time
the moon is flat
so
how would that happen
well a celestial body would need to spin
incredibly fast to become a flat disc
so fast that it would rip into tiny
pieces before it would ever have a
chance to form
for our purposes let's say the moon
survived this process and formed like a
plate
would this flat moon have the same mass
as what we see right now
well as a flat disc the moon could have
25
of the thickness but the width might
remain the same
with so much less mass floating above
the earth the change in ocean tides
could be the first noticeable effect
the moon's gravitational pull generates
these tides
our moon pulls the water on the side of
the earth that's closest to it but this
flat moon would have less mass and less
gravitational effect on our planet
and the altered tides would affect more
than just surfers
ocean tides stir up material below the
water's surface allowing coastal
ecosystems to thrive
without the usual strong waves animal
life in the oceans like crabs mussels
and snails could die off in mass numbers
this chain reaction could decimate life
worldwide
and that's not all a flat moon would
ruin
remember the tides also push water back
and forth around the planet
when warm waters travel from one area to
another these tidal forces change
weather patterns globally
without the strong tides we could
experience extreme temperature changes
but even with all these devastating
changes the climate still wouldn't
change as fast as the days
the moon's mass influences our planet's
rotation
giving us a 24-hour day
but with a flat moon
the day could be only 15 hours long
but i think most of us could live with a
five-hour workday
and while we'd get more sunlight
the nights would be even darker
you see the moon reflects the sunlight
to give off that bright glow we all know
and love
a smaller moon would reflect less light
making it much dimmer
that would make it harder for nocturnal
animals that rely on the moon for
navigation and hunting
but maybe none of that would matter
since it could potentially crash right
into us
wait what
yeah the earth and the moon are locked
together in an eternal dance
the motion created by one affects the
other
i know this sounds hippy-dippy but trust
me we're talking science here
the same tidal forces that move the
oceans
also affect the moon's orbit
the tidal bulges in the ocean rotate
faster than the moon orbits the earth
and this rotation takes energy away from
the earth and transfers that into the
moon's orbit
this is called tidal friction and causes
the moon to drift away from us at the
rate of
3.82 centimeters every year
a flat moon with less mass would orbit
closer to our planet
so
maybe it wouldn't slam into earth but
our view of celestial phenomena
wouldn't be the same
right now the sun and moon are
positioned just perfectly that when
aligned we get a spectacular image of a
total eclipse on earth
the moon covers the sun entirely in this
breathtaking event
a squished moon wouldn't be able to
block out the sun entirely during an
eclipse and we would see the top and
bottom of the sun peeking out
a flat moon could destroy the balance of
life on earth and threatens every
ecosystem and living organism
including humans
but
what if the conspiracy theorists were
right all along
what if the earth is flat
well get ready to scale the ice wall
because that's a story
for another what if